but I think that day one of the worse
predicaments that I've been in in my
life at that point the experience from
that has helped me I think through my
whole entire career that is Master
Sergeant Matthew o Williams recognized
with a Medal of Honor for heroic actions
in Afghanistan and the rescue of four
critically wounded soldiers the Medal of
Honor is the highest award in the United
States military given to a very few
selects who've shown extraordinary valor
of course there are some incredible
stories of courage behind those who have
received the award but many recipients
have never rested on their laurels
they've been helping others to find
their own measure of courage to live
life with the same selflessness they
displayed on the fields of battle I work
because I want people to see a message
that there's a different way to live
your life caring for others more than
yourself
Special Forces combat medic and Vietnam
veteran Gary biker was presented with
the Medal of Honor by President Richard
Nixon in 1973 on the battlefields badly
injured and unable to walk by Kirk still
braved enemy fire to save wounded
soldiers he credits a 15 year old named
ayo who befriended his team I said this
damn do you have to teach me how to
survive in the jungle and he laughed and
he said I don't want to teach you how to
survive I'm gonna teach you how to live
in the jungle surrounded and badly
outnumbered on April 1st 1970 the ground
assault team after being shot the first
time the next thing I remember was Dale
picking me up and carrying me around
everything that I did continuing to help
others I did only because daya was able
to carry me then Deo laid down his life
for his American friend we heard a
rocket coming in Dale rolled me over and
laid on top of me to protect me from the
rocket blast and he was killed by that
blast I have a new definition for
courage and that courage is just love in
action in its 157 year history the Medal
of Honor has been presented to just over
3500 individuals nearly half for actions
in the Civil War today there are only 69
living recipients
by Kirk and others are taking their
message to schools as part of the
character development program Farage is
not having the strength to go on it is
going on we don't have the strength
designed to teach values like courage
commitment sacrifice and integrity to
students K through 12
during the Cova 19 lockdown their
mission continues online by crooks
lesson came from the wall about a father
and son who visit the Vietnam Memorial
and the tears of families 96 year old
woody Williams also participated we push
an empty chair to the table the World
War two veteran read a story about a
seat at the dining table left empty to
acknowledge those missing in action
[Music]
Williams received his medal from
President Harry Truman in 1945 he was
recognized for actions against Japanese
forces at Iwo Jima as his fellow Marines
were cut down Williams used
flamethrowers to attack character he
says can overcome the deepest fears
you're not born with character somebody
has to teach that or once you get
character established then you build
certain foundations within yourself
assess your value of what life is all
about that opens the door for everyone
to be a better person
absolutely excellent there is no
restriction Moyna vowed to do everything
she could for the soldiers to remember
them the Society also recognizes
civilians who showed extraordinary
courage through its citizen honors award
like middle school counselor
Molly Hudgens I feel like it represents
the teachers and educators that we have
lost to school violence and gives me the
opportunity to share their stories and
also talk about their heroism Hudgens
was tested in 2016 when a 14 year old
brought a load
weapon to school even though I was
afraid I still had to try to manage the
situation we had a school full of
students and staff
I knew that really the only thing that
stood between him and then was me
Hudgens spoke with the boy for 90
minutes before he surrendered I remember
telling him what's right is never easy
but it's still right and he did that so
I'm not sure exactly what his future
will hold but I'm so grateful that he is
going to have a second chance how many
of you have obstacles in your life
they are teaching by example that living
a life of significance is achieved by
putting others first when they created
the day of July 4th so many many years
ago that it was a day to celebrate the
great values that we have in the
greatest country for CBS this morning
Saturday Catherine Herridge the Pentagon
you know thanks to Catherine for that
story Michelle I love what Molly Hudgens
that teacher who received the civilian
honor said she said we know what's right
is never easy but it's still right
that's right and being honored and then
sharing other stories about what they've
done to contribute I love that too